well here's a way of thinking about i've
been writing about this recently
what's real
matter it's like okay that's one answer
what's real
what matters is real
because that's how you act
okay that's different than matter
it's like okay
what's the most real of what matters
how about pain
why is it the most real
try arguing it away
good luck
so pain is the fundamental reality
all right
well that's rough
doesn't that lead to nihilism and
hopelessness
yeah doesn't it lead to a philosophy
that's antithetical towards being the
most fundamental reality is pain
yes
is there anything more fundamental than
pain
love
really
if you're in pain
love and truth
that's what you got
and you know
if they're more powerful than pain
maybe they're the most real things
when you think about reality what is
real that is the most real thing
well it's a tough one right because you
have to
because if you're a scientist a
materialist think well
the matter is the most real it's like
well you don't know what the matter is
yeah and so and then when push comes to
shove and it will
you'll find out what's most real yeah
i i feel like this is uh
missing
physical reality is is missing some of
the things
so of course pain has a biological
component and all those kinds of things
but it it's missing something deep about
the human condition that
at least the modern science is not able
to
describe but is it is reaching towards
that yeah it is the reason
one way to describe it as you're
describing is the reason it's reaching
it is because underneath of science is
this assumption that
there's a deep
logos
thing to this whole thing we're trying
to do
well you know there's two traditions
right in some sense there's two logos
traditions
there's the
the greek
rational
enlightenment tradition that's a logos
tradition and it insists that there's a
logos in nature and that science is the
way to approach it and then there's the
judeo-christian logos which is more
embodied and more spiritual and i would
say the west is actually an attempt to
unite those two
and it's the proper attempt to unite
those two
because they need to be united
and i see the union coming in near terms
you know i talked to france to wall for
example about the animating principle of
chimpanzee sovereignty
and that's pretty close biologically is
it power
because that's the claim even from the
biologists often the most dominant chimp
has the best reproductive success
it's like
oh yeah dominant eh you mean using
compulsion okay let's look
are the chimps who use compulsion
the most successful
and the answer is
sporadically and rarely
and for short well that's sporadically
for short periods of time why
because they meet an unpleasant end
the subordinates over whom they exercise
arbitrary control
wait for a weak moment and then tear
them into shreds
right
every dictator's terror
and for good reason and dewall has
showed that the alpha chimps the males
who do have preferential mating access
often
are often
and reliably
the best peacemakers and the most
reciprocal
and so even among chimps the principle
of sovereignty is something like
iterative iterated
reciprocity
and that's a way better principle than
power
and it's something like i've been
thinking what's the antithesis of the
spirit of power
i think it's the spirit of play
and you know you i don't know what you
think about that but when you have a
good podcast conversation you already
described it in some sense as play it's
like there's a structure right because
it's an ordered conversation but you
want there to be play in the system and
if you get that right then it's really
engaging
and then it seems to have its own
narrative arc i'm not trying to impose
that even though that's another thing i
don't do i didn't come to this
conversation
at all thinking here's what i want out
of a conversation with lex friedman like
instrumentally i thought
i'll go talk to lex why
i like his podcasts
he's doing something right i don't know
what it is he asks interesting questions
i'll go have a conversation with him
where's it gonna go
wherever it goes
embracing the spirit of play
you